[Applause]
I feel like for many years
it was I don't really know who we are
but
the store is the first time that I knew
who we are Imagine Dragons
[Applause]
but here we are
our goal was to be a self-sustained
Indie band that could make enough money
to pay rent and have food no idea that
it would be that's big that's one in a
billion for all past or Wildest Dreams
there's no words for an eye like this we
will give you everything because you
have given us everything
[Music]
people were playing for five people
Dan was still Larger than Life on stage
he's always been that guy
still feels like we're the hungry band
playing five nights a week every day
that we have is a gift
may we spend less time being divided may
we spend more time loving
more time forgiving I get a look at
look you cry and sing this song in the
top of their lungs
these years pass by and we're growing
older and I think of you
made it through I have lost too many
people who think that their life doesn't
matter your life always matters
[Applause]
[Music]
feel safe and mouth
it's a bigger stage but
nothing's really changed
[Music]
[Applause]